-As the world comes together
to condemn Putin's invasion
of Ukraine,
some are asking what more
the U.S. can do to stop him.
Here to discuss, please welcome
Republican strategist
Charles Reinke, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah, thanks for having me, Seth.
-Thanks for being here.
How many times have you been
on the show now?
-I have lost count.
I'd say somewhere
between 29 and 31.
-So, 30?
-Yep, yeah.
-Okay, great.
Now, when Russia invaded
Ukraine, quite a few Republicans
were actually praising Putin.
As a Republican yourself,
what do you think about that?
-It's always been my opinion
that anyone who ever said
something positive about Putin
should be ashamed.
Putin is a weak tyrant
who doesn't deserve
anyone's respect.
I would even go so far
as to say he's a moron.
-Now, see, that is interesting
because I'm pretty sure you've
said the exact opposite.
-Nah, I don't think that's true.
-Well, it is.
You said it on this very show.
Let's take a look at the tape.
-In my opinion,
Putin is a strong leader
who deserves everyone's respect.
I would even go so far
as to say he's a genius.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, Seth, that is --
that's really unfair.
-What's unfair?
-Well, you bringing me
on your show just to run an old
clip of me contradicting myself.
I hate "gotcha journalism."
It makes for a bad interview.
And frankly,
you should be ashamed.
-Now, see, that's not
what you said
the last time
you were on the show.
Let's take a look at the tape.
-I love "gotcha journalism."
It makes for
an exciting interview.
And frankly, if you ever did it
on your show,
you should be proud.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, alright. That -- I must
have said that years ago.
-No, that was in February.
-I wasn't on the show
in February.
-Let's look at the tape.
-Happy last day of
Black History Month 2022.
[ Laughter ]
-It was so weird
that you said that at the time.
-Yeah, well, I'm just trying to
be woke,
you know, like you, Seth.
Wake up!
[ Laughter ]
Is that what the kids
are saying now? Wake up?
-I don't know.
-Woke up?
-Yeah, okay.
-Seth, let's just get back to
talking about the issue at hand.
-I would love that.
Yeah, okay. Great.
-Putin invading Ukraine
is a real crisis.
-Roll the tape!
-Putin invading Ukraine
is a made-up crisis.
-Charles, are you doing
something different
with your hair?
-I stopped dying it.
This is my natural hair color.
I hate hiding my true self.
-So you're back to hiding
your true self?
-Well, I'm trying to date again.
Don't tell my wife.
[ Chuckles ]
Seth, you're taking everything
I say out of context.
For example, I think
the Marvel movies are boring
and I hate them,
but I'm sure you could find
some vague generic clip
that makes it seem like
I love those movies.
-Like this one?
-Avengers, assemble!
[ Laughter ]
Alright. This is a textbook
liberal hit job
to destroy my reputation.
-Sure.
-What are you going to do next?
Find some obscure radio clip
from 10 years ago
where I make
some crazy comment like,
"There should never be a Black
woman on the Supreme Court"?
-No, but I am going to play
the podcast you did for us
last time you were on the show.
-To answer your question,
I don't believe we should have
a Black woman
on the Supreme Court.
-My question was
boxers or briefs.
-Boxers.
Oh, and by the way, happy last
day of Black History Month 2022.
Looks like you got me.
[ Chuckles ]
You know what?
You know, I don't need this.
I'm never coming back
on this show.
-Well, you've said that before.
-No, I haven't.
-Roll it.
-I'm never coming back
on this show.
I'm never coming back
on this show!
on this show.
I'm never coming back
on this show!
on this show.
I'm never coming back
on this show!
on this show.
-Wait, was that last one me?
-No, it was me when I dressed up
as you for Halloween.
Happy Halloween 2021.
[ Laughter ]
-Charles Reinke, everyone!